within three days Gary lineker has gone
for one of the BBC's most loved faces to
one we won't be seeing any time soon
taken off air for breaching the
organization's impartiality rules
we've said that we consider his recent
social media activity to be a breach of
our guidelines the BBC has decided that
he will step back from presenting match
of the day until we've gotten agreed and
clear position on his use of social
media when it comes to Leading our
football and sports coverage they say
Gary is second to none we have never
said that Gary should be an opinion-free
zone or that he can't have a view on
issues that matter to him but we have
said that he should keep well away from
taking sides on party political issues
or political controversies
a source up close to the presenter
though says this decision to step back
wasn't his at all instead one taken
solely by the corporation he's also not
willing to apologize for his comments so
there's a standoff and one that's
causing quite the headache for those
Insider
in solidarity former footballers and
fellow broadcasters Ian Wright Alan
Shearer and Alex Scott are refusing to
appear on the program a Fallout that's
snowballing when the corporation would
have wanted it quashed well I can see
the BBC has a dilemma it has a presenter
who does want to say whatever he wants
to say but the BBC is saying we have
never said that Gary should be an
opinion-free Zone all that he can't have
a view on issues that matter to him and
I think that is going all in sort of
territory it's very difficult to work
out what can he and can't he say so this
is really from the BBC's point of view a
terrible and rather sad mess at the
moment it all started on Tuesday with
this tweet criticizing the government's
latest migration plan and comparing its
language to that used in 1930s Germany
the day after the broadcaster whose Long
supported refugees doubled down on his
views and the government then hit back
with the Home Secretary branding his
language offensive and his name propping
up in the Commons labor are borrowing
from the Gary lineker Playbook they are
a part
and the occasional left-wing Striker
which yet again ignited a response
it's led to a sanctioned some sea as
appropriate I wouldn't want to silence
anybody's opinions I know he'll argue
that he's not a politics presenter or a
news presenter or so on but he's clearly
overstepped the marker I mean what he
said was grossly offensive and he
doesn't seem to be showing any
Contrition for that whatsoever
whilst colleagues of linekers are
ramping up support in asking one of its
most popular faces to step back the BBC
is stepping towards more division
Sky News